welcome to this video shushing hi
double-o 8 yeah this guy is a frequent
opponent 50% dismiss gone 5 wins 5
losses two draws so and his god is
really high rating him
not sure I mean thinking he's high rated
usually but this is really high but ok
my mind is also not that bad
okay we got a Bishop f4 I'm sorry a
Bishop f4 line of the Queen's Gambit b6
I cannot trade on d5 now as it he has
committed to b6 this is probably an idea
Bishop to d3 yeah this whole yeah this
even makes a long castling attractive
with G form coming hmm yeah I mean it's
very it's really hard to resist when he
plays h6 voluntarily okay so if I take a
six now Knight a six will come to will
come to to a six to be formed okay I'm
kicking it I'm kicking off here with G
form I think you think about it
it takes on the 323 Knight g4
there are some issues f2 hangs which is
not so great
hmm
that's still very dangerous Bishop takes
Queen takes Knight g4 g one night f2
Queen f5 this is very dangerous that can
even consider to not play rook g1
immediately I can also go rook D to G
one really not caring about h1 falling
I don't think he can take after this
really looks looks unplayable to me
let's see even group g7 is very
dangerous but Queen f5 is I think
totally sufficient Knight xh1 Bishop
takes h6 wins at least I don't see a
defense after that g6 route g6 yeah and
now I go Queen to h5 or I can sacrifice
now let's have a look maybe I can
sacrifice now Ruby 7 King takes root d1
check
or the chick first f6 again a check King
King to age eight queen g6 that's that
sets over Jack you're not going to
survive this absolutely not
Jack Bishop f6 Queen f6
kingi a drug Chi oneness is very easy f6
rook g1 check King h8 Queen g6 and
that's it made on g7 or g8 or h6j and
queen g6 there see no defense against it
simply far too many threats Queen g c g7
made Queen h6 made and this I overlooked
but it's probably not mattering much
cannot believe this is should her word I
can give this check here
hmm don't tell me this is for some
reason not winning I would be really
disappointing I don't see a window
why did I forget this move really Jack I
don't even see a drone which is the
worst part time morning you want you
want at least a drummer here night h4
for Queen f5 mate maybe I have no time
oh what a game
you can give this chick him I don't know
jack I have to be really quick here
maybe I could have taken it but I'm not
I'm not really sure the still Queen f5
made yes this is possible I can give the
check here and again I check Jack of
course and then I had a checkmate here
in this game totally clear that I did
not see what is she after this I mean
what he played here was really really
bad I mean really really really really
bad check check
check
jack jessee's surviving by check just
just barely back but it is sufficient
Jack Jack hey I am come on
I totally overlooking a seven-yard in a
position where there was a force made
definitely definitely
so let's see how how black is check
medium the computer only gives a draw
which I find amazing because this is
totally insane what black did here
taking on g4 and f2 and everything and
not going to get checkmated as immensely
lucky she got ok this check and this it
seems it's just so wrong or maybe the
companies are to find the winner I
cannot believe that this isn't the win
I'm attacking with everything here that
that's that it cannot be it cannot be
true but I came let's see f6 Josh check
King f7 and ok the confines are drawn
check with 92 but not a winner which is
really really remarkable 92 for the
drama
yeah ok Knight f4 made I it is difficult
I would this time to be to be precise
this does not seem to be sufficient but
92 seems to be at least at all midnight
a form
the comic gives a bishop before as the
move leading to the draw and now Queen
takes 86 now white the check is
immensely strong but I cannot really
believe there isn't a win there I mean
really what is to come giving here just
Queen c2 with the big advantage I know
it's going down again the valuation hmm
Queen c2 wins okay yeah I mean there
must be some win this is crazy you
cannot just take g4 and f2 and be a page
six was also I mean this is just
terribly bad move cannot play that but
this is the refutation quincy tomb hmm
yeah okay McQueen at five I was really
thinking that Luke g7 should win
so I played Queen f5 why is this winning
yeah because while the knight has no
squares and where should it go take the
rook okay going to take here with g7
threatened Bishop f6 Knight g5 and this
is going to be going to be deadly
yeah this is never possible and the best
that I can do is Queen f6 Shaq go for go
for this position
yeah you for Queen cheeks this is a
terrible position why just has a
fantastic attack and I will get the
knight back whenever I want this is not
developed and so this was right yep I
it's amazing him I was really really
surprised that he there's no there's no
wynia a Bishop h6 also wins and I sorry
this is the wrong position I'm sorry I
went here and this is just Brandi
holding now this is immensely lucky air
that this is chapter I mean there are
tons of easy draws of course I mean I
saw this one
this is the very easy way to just draw
it but of course I didn't want to draw
the game not after what black played
earlier Queen age fryer there is no
wynia if the computer finds no way near
then there is no win this is completely
completely tactical of just and she I
really overlooked the king of seven Jack
yeah so I have to take the draw with
Queen G 6cm check well I didn't see that
as a draw of course otherwise jacket he
told us that he's even losing check yeah
this is a really strong attack +4 yeah I
guess this counts as losing yeah the
Queen c2 was the ki-moon's yeah I played
Queen f5 really too quickly it just
looked like the totally normal
continuation as well Bishop h6 is a huge
threat and I really thought that rook g7
would win or gap a combination of g7 but
it seems to be only sufficient for a
draw amazingly okay well thanks for
watching